hey Leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ja ich
weiß ich sehr zerzaust aus ich befinde
mich hier gerade in Paris wir machen uns
weiter auf die Reise Zügen Alter cool
das ist ja perfekt für mich hier kann
man einfach Schach spielen oder was ja
hier setze ich mich mal eben hin boah
ich bin ganz schön am schwitzen ey
wollen Sie vielleicht gegen mich Schach
spielen ja Leute was geht ich bin in
Paris für alle die sich fragen warum bin
ich hier ich mache gerade eine Zugreise
von London mit verschiedensten coolen
Zügen bis nach Paris stop stimmt nicht
bis nach Istanbul nicht Paris das wäre
ja nicht weit gewesen Istanbul ich habe
schon ein echt wilden Zug getestet von
London bis hier das war der erste Park
checken auf jeden Fall ab falls sie doch
nicht gesehen habt so Leute hier haben
wir ihn den Eurostar der für nach Paris
das ist meiner der hier fährt glaube ich
nach Amsterdam oder so es gibt natürlich
auch noch andere Ziele okay
und wir machen uns jetzt auf den Weg
hier zum Bahnhof weil hier fährt gleich
mein TGV tut tut für meine
Französischlehrerin hat immer gesagt
ja das ist das erste Mal dass ich den
teste ich habe mir natürlich die First
Class gebucht also erste Klasse wir
checken jetzt gleich hier am Bahnhof ich
weiß nicht wie oft ist diese Lounge gibt
aber in Paris gibt es auf jeden Fall
eine THW First Class Lounge die bei mir
natürlich auch mit dabei ist wir schauen
uns das mal an und gucken wie der Zug so
ist aber mir gefällt am Ende gibt's zu
Bewertung und ich habe richtig Bock weil
irgendwann in zwei oder drei Tagen bin
ich vielleicht in Istanbul also was
heißt vielleicht das ist der Plan nur
mit Zug das haben noch nicht viele
gemacht hier noch mal das Flüsschen
Paris ist einfach nice das Gute ist ja
auch an Paris man kann einfach die
Verkehrsregeln missachten das hört ihr
keine macht jeder so ich bin auf jeden
Fall schon da gardinand merci merci so
und da ja perfekt also ich könnte auf
jeden Fall eine Dusche gebrauchen aber
ich glaube nicht dass sie dann eine
Dusche haben weil ich bin so am
schwitzen ne ihr wisst nicht wie lange
schon unterwegs und das ist kein Ende in
16 noch in final in sichtbar
okay Leute wir sind im Bahnhof ah das
steht schon ich habe mich übrigens eben
vertan das heißt nicht First Class das
heißt Salon Grand Voyager da kann ich
jetzt auf jeden Fall hingehen schauen
wir mal ich hätte natürlich auch einfach
ganz normale Tickets buchen können aber
ich dachte mir wenn ich das jetzt schon
mal mache dann will ich euch natürlich
auch ein bisschen was bieten ne deswegen
Leute alle hier groß abonnieren da würde
ich mich sehr freuen ah da ist es ja
schon schön sorry
ja ich sag einfach zu ihm Gras hier ist
und der guckt mich an das bekommt man
denn hier hin ey gucken gibt für mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also so besondere Sachen gibt es auf
jeden Fall nicht aber an Wasser Kaffee
das reicht auf jeden Fall hier kann ich
jetzt gut chillen
so Leute ich bin jetzt hier in Halle 2
und von hier aus fährt jetzt mein Zug
los hier gibt's auf jeden Fall drei
verschiedene Hallen da kann man es ja
sehen Zürich steht da ich habe auch
überlegt ob ich diesen Zug nehme weil
das wäre auch ziemlich nice wir müssen
auf jeden Fall zugleich neun let's go ah
guck mal wie geil Alter und Leute die
kein Ticket haben kommen erst gar nicht
zum Zug das müssen in Deutschland auch
mal einfangen das gibt's doch nicht oh
die wollen alle auch nach Zürich glaube
ich hier die Kollegas so hier haben wir
meinen Ticket
Wagen 12 Platz 45
Alter hier ist Wagen eigentlich muss bis
ganz hinten ey ich habe auch irgendwie
das Gefühl der TGV ist viel länger als
ein ICE und der ist sogar doppelstöckig
und scheint so als wird er pünktlich
abfahren auch schon mal gut was geht
hier ab achso hier kommt wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen Getränke rein ne oder
geldgummi das weiß ich gar nicht ob ich
auch was zu essen mit dabei habe lassen
wir uns mal überraschen die einzige
übrigens auf jedem Waggon drauf
wir wurden schon oft gesagt dass die
Plätze so gemütlich sein sollen im TGV
wo ist denn jetzt hier 45 ich bin den
Wagen 13 toll
stabil okay Leute angekommen nicht viel
los hier aber Leute wollen natürlich
trotzdem ihre Ruhe haben denke ich mal
also ich würde schon sagen die Plätze
sind bequemer als im ICE die macht zwar
ein bisschen komische Geräusche aber man
hatte schon wirklich super viel space
ich bin auch schon mal ICE 1 Klasse
Gefahren zwar erst zwei Mal oder einmal
oder so warum auch brauche ich halt
eigentlich nicht aber hier hast du schon
wirklich die Ruhe weg ne ach so das habe
ich noch gar nicht gesagt ich fahre
jetzt vier Stunden vier glaube ich bis
nach Zürich und die Zahle 200 Euro habe
ich bezahlt also wer schon relativ viel
mal gucken was mein Resümee sein wird ob
man hier auch ein Käffchen bekommt 200 €
ist natürlich schon eine Stange Geld
aber schauen wir mal was wird achso
Leute und für dies interessiert wir
haben jetzt gerade Montag ihr könnt ja
mal kommentieren wann denkt ihr komme
ich in Istanbul an an was für ein Tag
also Donnerstag ja Donnerstag wäre ein
bisschen spät ich hoffe das klappt
früher so tschüss Paris es war mir eine
Ehre auch wenn ich nicht nur zwei
Stunden gesehen habe
und Leute für alle die nicht wissen wo
es hingeht heute fährt die 18 bis nach
Istan meine Damen und Herren
herzlich willkommen an Bord unseres
Zuges nach Zürich Leute schaut mal wie
cool man kann das hier so vor also
normal fahren und dann so in
Rückenposition eigentlich kann man sich
im TGW in der ersten Klasse auch das
Essen bis zum Platz bringen lassen nur
dafür brauchst du halt jemanden der dich
fragt ob du was essen willst und das kam
keiner also habe ich mal die Bar
abgecheckt da gibt's wirklich ein
vielfältiges Angebot auch so warme
Speisen sogar Fleisch viele verschiedene
Varianten ich habe mich dann für eine
Pizza Margarita entschieden für 8,50 €,
30 sogar noch im Rahmen war halt nicht
viel aber für eine Zug Pizza war die
echt gut
so wir sind jetzt gerade über die Grenze
gefahren in die Schweiz Halt und jetzt
haben wir sofort in Basel nach echt
anstrengend heute
ich habe auf jeden Fall dann noch ein
bisschen die Aussicht genossen also es
war jetzt auch nicht so spektakulär
Frankreich ist schon ganz schön und ich
würde auch sagen wenn man in Frankreich
mit dem zugreis ist die Landschaft
unterm Strich schon cooler als in
Deutschland wobei es in Deutschland auch
echt schöne Strecken gibt muss man sagen
ja insgesamt war ich etwas über 4
Stunden unterwegs von Paris nach Zürich
wenn auch wirklich pünktlich angekommen
ich glaube ich hatte vier Minuten
Verspätung das ist so gerade noch okay
ich bin viel viel schlimmeres gewohnt oh
Alter endlich angekommen boah ich bin so
fertig Leute ey ich brauche jetzt
erstmal ganz dringend was zu trinken
Smoothie oder so und dann hoffe ich dass
ich wieder zu Kräften komme so Leute was
geht ich bin in Zürich angekommen chille
jetzt irgendwo an einem Bahnsteig ich
habe keinen Plan von welchem Gleis mein
Nachtzug ist gleich fährt weil am
liebsten würde ich jetzt hier pennen
danach und erstmal klar kommen weil ich
bin seit 12 Stunden unterwegs oder so
war zwar an sich eine bequeme Reise aber
es geht trotzdem irgendwann voll so auf
die Nerven naja ich freue mich jetzt auf
jeden Fall auf mein Nachtzug der wird
glaube ich cool hoffe ich mal wenn ich
Pech habe nicht weil ich bin mir nicht
so ganz sicher was ich da gebucht habe
aber bevor es losgeht müssen wir noch
kurz bewerten und zwar den letzten Zug
das will ich ja jetzt mal machen habe
ich im letzten Fahrt auch gemacht erste
Klasse mit dem TGW von Paris nach Zürich
Comfort war top kann man nichts sagen
also Sitz bequem muss ich auf jeden Fall
55 Sterne geben Essen habe ich mir
selber geholt also da kam keiner hat
mich gefragt ob ich was essen ist auf
jeden Fall bei der Deutschen Bahn
ähnlich soweit ich weiß wobei man das
schon manchmal so nach dem Kaffee
gefragt wird möchten Kaffee trinken
möchten ein Stück Kuchen essen in der
ersten Klasse meine ich die Pizza war
okay und deutlich besser als alles was
ich jemals bei der Deutschen Bank
gegessen habe deswegen gibt es hier drei
von fünf Sterne aber mehr ist halt auch
nicht drin weil so geil was jetzt auch
nicht trotzdem muss ich sagen das ist
Angebot was ist dort zu essen gibt
deutlich krasser ist als bei der
deutschen Mann zumindest auch das was
die vorrätig haben da gab es echt viel
Auswahl das war schon ganz gut Service
war so ja die haben halt mein Ticket
kontrolliert und waren auf jeden Fall
alle nett also das kann ich sagen sehr
sehr nett würde ich auch mal von fünf
Sterne geben naturerlebnisfaktor ja gut
das ist bei sonderstrecke jetzt nicht so
wild zwei von fünf Sterne preis Leistung
ist okay erste Klasse ist halt in
Deutschland genauso teuer kann ich
eigentlich nichts sagen 200 € für die
Strecke würde ich auch nur drei Sterne
geben so 150 jetzt auch getan oder 140
okay das war der zweite Zug auf der
Reise ich muss mich jetzt beeilen weil
ich will auf jeden Fall passen in mein
Schlafabteil ich bin nämlich echt müde
hier ist mein nightjet 21:40 Uhr nach
Wien Hauptbahnhof Leute abonniert den
Kanal übermorgen geht's weiter mit
dieser ganzen tollen Serie hier und wir
ja Digger ich weiß dass der Scheiß Zug
jetzt von woanders fährt man Zeug ich
bin ein bisschen genervt haut rein Leute
man muss durchhalten ich will da
irgendwann Istanbul ankommen ciao